even steve how are you all right bud
where are you
yeah right thanks mate not bad at all do
you know chair we're now live on youtube
thank you so is andrew ready
yes i am thank yes it's good to be with
you again
thank you andrew for your prayers that's
very good
and uh i think we'll start with uh with
your good self
and um welcome the members of the public
who are watching on youtube
and of course fellow counselors are
listening as well so if you'd like to go
ahead please do
thank you very much let us pray
loving god in this time of advent we
look ahead to the christmas season with
hope and anticipation
in the coming of jesus we see light and
love for the world
in all the darkness and suffering so
many people are experiencing
at this time of pandemic and generally
in lives and communities
we see lights in the choir of angels
appearing to the shepherds
surrounded by the radiance of your glory
gracious god
as those angels offer praise at the
birth of jesus
we see light too in the star guiding the
wise men
in their long journey to bethlehem to
meet with jesus
mary and joseph and this light added to
their wisdom and understanding
and so we seek and work towards and with
this same light of hope
love and peace you offer us in christ
in particular for all those living and
working
in the torridge district council area as
we meet this evening
holy god may the light of your wisdom
grace and compassion
guide and nurture the discussions and
decisions of this council meeting
and all the work which follows it for
jesus christ's sake
amen amen and you are invited to
share in the words of the lord's prayer
our father who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy will be done on earth as it is in
heaven
give us this day our daily bread and
forgive us our trespasses
as we forgive those who trespass against
us
amen
thank you andrew um may i wish you and
all your congregation a very happy
christmas
despite the circumstances we find
ourselves in
thank you very much and may i wish you
the greetings of the season as well and
uh
i wish you all well for the christmas
period thank you very much
thank you we'll see talk to you again
soon i hope so
i think we've got two minutes haven't we
tom
uh yes chad make it four four oh
we still got people joining at the
moment
um
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
chair i'll make that 6 30. very much tom
well good evening uh fellow councillors
and members of the public are joining us
on youtube
uh welcome to this full council meeting
of the 14th of december
2020. i am in the festive spirit i have
got a
father christmas time as you can see um
the rest of you have as well but there
you are okay so i'm going to uh
begin first of all as normal with um
the uh register and apologies for
absence
so kirsty if you'd like to do the honors
thank you chair i've received apologies
from councillor manly
um i'll go through the register now
thank you councillor belton
yeah i'm here councillor brenton
president councillor bright yeah
councillor brown president
councillor bushby president councillor
christie
president councillor clark president
councillor cottle hunkin president
craigie
counselor craigie no she's not present
yet kirsty
thank you councillor dart
present thank you councillor ford
president councillor gov president
councillor hackett
president
councillor hodgson president councillor
hurley
president councillor hutchings yeah
councillor inch president councillor
james
councillor jones
and no he's not present yet kirsty thank
you councillor langford
president council of laws present
councillor leather councillor locke
president councillor mcgoff
present councilor mckenzie
no he's not present yet thank you
councillor newton
president councillor pennington
councillor rossi
no he's not present yet either thank you
councillor watson
councillor wiseman
no he's not present yet either okay
thank you
right thank you uh kirsty
so counselors go to item two and as you
can see that's the council minutes and
we have
uh four sets now i'm sure you're all
looking forward to this
but the way i propose to do it is to
take them a whole lot on block
now if you were absent for one and you
wish to abstain
if you would identify that one or
those ones uh please say so when you
give approval for the rest of it we are
actually only looking for accuracy of
the minutes
so you've got october 26 november the
2nd
november the 16th and november the 30th
so if you say approval for example
but you wish abstain from saying
november the 16th please say
november 16th abstain and then at the
end
if there are any questions vis-a-vis
updates and now normally we actually
don't have matters arising on our
we shouldn't do it but in these times i
will
be indulging as long as it's not too
long-winded and not too many of them
either i mean but in the first instance
it's
purely the accuracy of the minutes i'll
move out those four sets of minutes
chair
thank you very much councillor leather
second there
is a lot right so if you're saying
councillor bushfield's raised his hand
sure councillor bushby
are you going to move them sorry
i've been beaten to the to the drool i
was going to move the minutes but
okay then right we'll we'll um make a
start on that and
see see we progress i am not going to
read the pages out you've
all had an opportunity to read them so
uh we'll just go through to the straight
all right kirstie are you
all ready with poison yes i'm ready
thank you
councillor belton yeah approve all of
them
thank you councillor brenton
approval counselor bright
approval councillor brown
approval counselor bushby
likewise councillor christie
approval councillor clark
approval councillor cottle honking
approval has councillor craigie joined
no she hasn't thank you councillor dart
approve oh approve all but abstain from
second of november
so not approval approved all but the 2nd
of november sorry
thank you councillor ford
approve but i'm not sure because it was
one
i think there's one i couldn't get into
i spoke with the officers so it's either
the 30th of november the one before but
i'm not sure
actually i'll put my hand up and be
guilty so you might have to research on
that
thank you very much
thank you councillor approval
councillor hackett approve all
councillor haines approval
councillor harding approval about the
first
meeting in november abstain
thank you councillor hawkins approval
councillor heporn approval
councillor hicks approval
councillor hodgson approve all
councillor hurley rubell
councillor hutchings
um approve all but the second of
november
which is an abstention thank you
councillor inch approval
councillor james bouville
jones approval
councillor langford approve all
councillor laws approval
counselor leather or all
counselor lock approve all
councillor mcgoff yes for all
councillor mackenzie
still not present thank you councillor
newton
approval councillor pennington
approve all has councillor russia joined
no he hasn't thank you councillor watson
approval and has councillor wiseman
joined
no he hasn't either okay thank you all
done
thank you very much kersey that was
relatively painless
now are there any uh as i say we don't
have matters of rising but
if there was any queries on that any of
that please indicate now
councillor hawkins i see is hands raised
is that right
i know yeah thank you yes it was just
briefly to tell you that um
councillor mckenzie's sent his apologies
uh something's come up
all right okay okay thank you very much
for that that's good
uh councillor haines yeah thank you
just um just to comment again on the
huge
quantity of paper that has been sent to
us
so so thick that was bursting out of the
envelope
um and i'm minded to put a resolution
forward that we
reduce the amount of paper used for
agendas and minutes
at some point thank you right
again okay we put something in the
members bulletin last week asking any
members who don't want to receive paper
copies anymore to contact them services
and we'll remove them from the mailing
list
fair enough thank you very much so
all right um tom i can't say anymore so
we'll move on
to number three which is public
contributions uh
we don't have any do we yes we have one
sorry we have yes chair from uh the
atlantic wreckage center ah yes of
course we have but that's that's at the
back of the agenda isn't it
is it the same one or they added stuff
um it's a statement they've submitted
its chair
oh if it was very sim it's very similar
to the appendix
um okay so it's it reads
firstly we'd like to thank the members
officers and staff of tdc for the
support you have given so far the time
you have given to consider our request
for this hundred thousand pound
loan we are truly within striking
distance of completing the main areas of
our facility which will then enable us
to provide a comprehensive range of
sports and activities
in a safe and comfortable environment to
improve the health and well-being of the
community
embracing all aspects of diversity and
inclusion we are currently drawing down
375 000 funding gained from the lta
which has enabled us to complete all
ground and external work which included
all exterior lighting and the opening of
our new car park last month
however we still need a hundred thousand
from tdc to complete the current phase
which will see the m e change rooms
toilets and gym completed without this
many will not be able to open
any of these additional facilities this
community facility is was already
a real asset for the people of torridge
district and at this very difficult
period of time it has never been more
needed
our members and users who also access
our coaching program come from all over
torridge district
including torrington montgomery with
giffords holdsworthy heather lee hartman
brad with these slips cross little m
park and buckland brewer sheepwash
woolsey hi bickenton winkby kaveli
alva discard biddeford north and
westwood hall and appledore
we even attract from father of fields
such as such places as bowed and hoverly
during the recent lockdown almost 90
percent of our members continue to pay
their subscription
which shows how much the center and his
staff are valued while the center was
closed this did not stop us working with
our community
our coaching staff went into schools to
deliver physical education to cover
for teachers who were off because of the
coving pandemic
also since march we've opened the center
as much as the regulations allowed
despite it not being financially viable
because of the restrictions
we had to operate under to keep us
covered compliant
we did this because we recognized the
need for all our users and the local
community to mainly
maintain their health and well-being
this included sessions for the clients
of northern caretrust with their complex
and special needs who really benefited
from these activities
we hope you will agree with us that arc
truly is a
community charity that needs and
deserved deserves your continued support
a reminder of the facts we have
charitable organization and we opened
our doors
to the community in 2015 when we had 16
floodlit outdoor tennis courts and a
temporary clubhouse
in january 2018 we opened our indoor
sports hall with four
indoor tennis courts and three badminton
courts on opening we had around 80 users
per week
and currently we are now over 100 1
100 weekly visitors since opening our
outreach program has been through a
period of significant
significant development and is thriving
with a multitude of users
in addition once completed we hope to
add one additional badminton court ten
table tennis
tables two squash courts two fitness
studios a gym a bar and cafeteria
changing rooms toilets offices and a car
park
additionally it will provide specialist
amenities for disabled individuals
through the provision of a change in
places facilities
arc is a community community charity
accessible affordable and inclusive for
the whole community in toronto
district it's working with schools all
over the district from heartland
wall street torrent and outward or
northern biddeford 16
primary that includes acct a partners
partner organization and three secondary
is working with two scn schools lampard
and pathfield schools
provide sessions for three link
behavioral schools marlins
shoreland a shoreline academy and wave
mat a household of four can join for as
little as eight pound month that's just
two pound each
anyone can book a tennis or badminton
court and pay and play without joining
as a member
our three badminton courts are currently
available 30 hours per week i'm running
it near full capacity
i nearly added two table tennis tables
are currently available 30 hours a week
our four indoor courts are currently
fully booked most weeknights pre-covered
our six outdoor courts are extremely
busy since reopening for
following lockdown runs we run a large
range
of sessions and classes from cardio
tennis walking tennis tops tennis
learning disability tennis and badminton
for all ranges from three
up to no limit runs a range of
competitions for all ages with a
flagship event in may attracting over
300 entries from the south west and
beyond
it's fully accessible and works closely
with the clients of northern caretrust
and in addition once every month they
run an inclusive hassle for
anyone with any form of disability from
learning disabilities to physical
run six open and free community days
every year with 221 people attending
each event
on average it's working with many
community groups
torrington u3a devon learning recovery
services exercise for mental health
scouts groups and cabs
3230 children access for each
tennis every year 12 920 children
experience tennis since the center
opened in 2015
now has over 650 members and over 330
people on weekly coaching program
over 1 112 people visit center every
week
have over 50 volunteers who work with
the three full-time staff and nine
part-time staff once completed and fully
open arc will generate at least 15 new
jobs for members of the local community
and are planning to on running a
mentoring and volunteering service to
help get disadvantaged and unemployed
people
the skills and experience they need to
get to the workplace
arc of raise over a thousand pound to
provided defib which is available
available to the community of cadstone
arc have raised over 20 000 to install
the change in places
disable disability toilet and changing
facility which will be open to the whole
community irrespective of them using
arc arc have already raised over 2.9
million
but they now really need the last 100
000 pounds
thank you chair thank you very much
steve that was an example of speed
reading at its best
very good so um thank you for that we'll
move on then to
declarations of interest um well you
know what the
procedure is there the councillors
declare it at the time when the
item is on the agenda in which you have
an interest and we've got number five
agreement of agendas between part one
and two there
there is no part two but but
under chairman's business um we need to
uh raise the 1610 issue and at that time
when we get to the end of the agenda
we will take a vote to go into part two
because that
comes under chairman's business uh then
we go on to
seven questions under procedure rule uh
a9
we haven't got any of those either have
we
no no chair thank you very much and then
eight is localization the council tax
support and those are on pages 83 to 100
and uh who's dealing with that that's um
which officer is heading that chair
it it's going to be jo wells um the refs
and ben
benefits and revenues manager and before
i hand over to her
i'm just gonna just inform members that
um
no local authorities are proposing to
update their scheme
this year and the reason being is it
takes extensive consultation to change
the scheme
and extensive manpower and the other
authorities are proposing waiting
for the um outcome of the pandemic
um before changing and that's what torij
would like to do
so sit back establish what assistance
people
need um as a result of the pandemic and
then um
we proposed to change the scheme at that
that stage but
i'll hand over to jay wells now just to
explain the background because she's
been working with members
on the working group thank you for that
you know we'd like to lead on that
please
yes good evening i'm i'm here to
to propose the report to
roll over the scheme for council tax
support from 2020
on to 21 22 and to obtain
approval for the current exceptional
hardship policy to roll over to 2122
as a introduction the council tax
support scheme was introduced back in
2013
it took over from council tax benefits
when that was abolished by the
government
the government they tasked all local
authorities to actually come up with
their own local council tax support
scheme
this is for working age customers only
as the the
schemes for pensioners is actually
prescribed by the government
torres district council support scheme
hasn't changed since implementation in
april 2013 and
only affects customers who are of
working age
the devon authorities have historically
worked in partnership in an attempt to
promote the common
and consistent approach to the
individual schemes across devon
although we continue to work in
partnership the schemes have
changed slightly where by southampton
west devon moved to an income banded
scheme
1920 team bridge north east and mid
devon moved to an income banded scheme
in 2021 excuse me
20 20 21. exeter and ourselves were
planning to move to an income branded
scheme from 2021 to 22
but stacy has stated unfortunately due
to
the covered pandemic that hasn't been
we haven't been able to actually work
towards that due to the increase
in work that has come through with
regards to
the impact
in march 9 2019 a member working
group and officer working group was set
up and
we had met a couple of times to discuss
changing the scheme from
2021 however as
i've already stated unfortunately that
hasn't
expanded any due to the fact that in
february and march of this year
several key officers who would have been
involved with the
looking at the changing the scheme
actually left the employment of toronto
district council
and has stated the covert pandemic has
has also meant that we haven't been able
to continue with that
the cost of the scheme has increased
slightly
from the previous year at october it was
four million 153 pounds
however in addition to the amount of
cost to our scheme we also had
a covert 19 hardship fund which was
money that was funded
in order to enable any working age
customer in receipt of council tax
support
to actually have an additional amount of
monies up to 150 pounds towards their
council tax liability
and as at the end of october 2020
we'd awarded an extra 333 000
on to customers council tax accounts
the number in the caseload has reduced
slightly
even though the amount of universal
credit claims in the torridge district
of the bidding betty ford job center has
doubled since the same time last year
however
not all of those people would actually
be liable for council tax
so although those figures have doubled
that doesn't necessarily
necessarily impact on our council tax
support claims
in addition to not much movement within
our working age caseload i think that
has
been impacted by the fact that we
haven't pursued any recovery
during this year due to the pandemic or
with the way we did start
issuing reminders and summonses with
with regards to customers in october
and the first summonses were issued on
the 16th of november 2020.
our exceptional hardship fund has
also been quite low again this year but
in addition to the awards that we can
potentially
award customers due to the extra 333 000
from the covet
hardship fund i think that's why that
amount has
remained quite low
um so in conclusion we
are required as a local authority to
have its own
local council tax support scheme as part
of the welfare reform proposals
introduced by central government
as well as or generating savings
so um it's recommended that
the scheme for 2020 is rolled over to
2021 22 and that the exceptional
hardship scheme
is rolled over to 2021-22
all right thank you thank you very much
joe
uh the recommendations counselors on
page 87
are there any questions before i um move
the recommendations on page 87
council lock yeah just one small point
on page 94
item number 10 bullet point two i would
have thought if anyone just gets paid
out for one week
it costs more administration costs to
grant that for one week i just
wonder how many cases do we know when it
was given for one week only
the joke can you answer that
i'm sorry what are you referring to
what's being paid out for one week yeah
sorry what's being paid out for one week
well um
what's on there the exceptional
hardships
awarded for one week and i would have
thought administration costs would have
more than covered what they get paid out
for one week and i just wondered how
many cases they paid for one week
i don't know how many people would
qualify for
sorry for one week
remember
good um
okay should we look into that and uh
provide a response to our members
yeah she come back with an answer to you
later on that one
yes that's fine thank you thank you uh
councillor leathers next i think
thank you chair just a couple of
questions one is on eight page 85.
no have been issued between february
2020 and october
due to the pandemic recovery for the
current record
year recommenced october 2020 with the
first summons is being issued
16th of november isn't that a bit of a
short-sighted policy i've
had people in biddeford telling me that
nobody's chased them up at all for
council tax this year
and yet some of them i i do appreciate
some people i've had
financial difficulties but surely those
that could
afford to pay should have been able to
make to pay
and not chasing those arrears up over
the years
is to me has been a bad policy
and the other thing was lead member
councillor hudson talking about
uh the scheme will be undertaken next
year i take it that's 2021
because it does need looking at does
this scheme
the other issue is savings of only six
thousand pounds storage allows
claimants and that's a miserable meager
sum of money
lots of councils twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen thousand price savings
uh and six thousand now they're here
there to most people
but i just wonder why we've not been
chasing up people who could play this
year
all right is there an answer to that one
please
yes should i come in on that um it was
agreed
uh with all devil authorities that we we
would put
collection on hold um try
awaiting the outcome of the pandemic
people were losing their jobs having
reduced hours
um so it was felt that
it was best in that time period to to
not do any collection
um have to say though um we did do
gentle reminders throughout that period
it was um
the info formal enforcement action that
that was stopped so we we stopped the
court action but
to be honest the courts were shut during
that period anyway
um and we stopped any um
formal legal proceedings but during the
period the teams were still
writing to people reminding them but it
was um
agreed with the lead members as well
that we would do gentle reminders and
actually
um that that went fairly well for us um
with the formal um action in beginning
in october
thank you very much thank you councillor
pennington's next
uh thank you chair mike i wanna i
congratulate the officers because
they've had an
awfully difficult year this year to do
all they've done so i've got one or two
really good comments coming through um
my you know i know prince william said
people weren't being chased up
but to cook with they had what they've
had to cook with i take my hat off to
them
um i just want to ask a question on page
96
which is the comparisons between the
districts in devon
and very specifically on the uh fourth
line down the minimum income floor for
self-employed
and we are the only district to have a
no when all the other districts have
yes's
i just wonder if you can explain to me
how that affects their self-employed
claim
because um i gather self-employed in our
area now because they weren't earning
anything before
when they've gone under universal credit
they're actually getting more money than
they were when they were working which
is quite a strange thing
um and that's particularly for the
hospitality industry um
talking to one or two who are out of
work and how do you claim universal
credit so can you just explain with the
only
district with a no with all the others
with the yeses and how does that
impact on a uh claimant who is liable to
pay
council tax on the property joe thank
you
sure yep thank you councillor pennington
the page that you're referring to that's
the schemes for 2019
20. so if you go down to the bottom of
that page and to the next page
it has the updated figure the updated
date of 2021 but we are still the
local authority that doesn't have a
minimum income floor for self-employed
and that's actually a good thing because
that means that any
monies that a customer declares as
self-employed
we would use that income minus any
expenses
whereas if somebody is not declaring any
income
with the authorities that are taking
into account a minimum income floor they
will base
a customer having income and i think it
they base it on 35 hours on the
national living wage so they would
actually
excellent joe thank you for that answer
that answers exactly what i wanted to
hear thank you very much
thank you councillor ford is next
yeah um just want to make sure perhaps
i've got long and the stickier
um could be clarified then because
perhaps it is about people on income are
we still
however chasing
historic debt as you guys cancelled cats
because
i'm aware of someone
uh an address at easter water in the
last
four to six weeks it actually did a
bailiff so do
um the firmware employ uh as you guys
bayless
are they still active thank you
answer should i answer that chair um
yeah we started a formal enforcement
action and that that includes
historic debts councillor ford um
we had um
stopped the bailiffs for for a
significant period through the march to
october
period but um they have been
reinstructed
now thank you for that thank you
councillor hodson
next thank you very much mr chairman
um i do commend this report to you
the issue of uh trying to consult on a
new scheme
was not practicable for this coming year
uh to be able to introduce a new scheme
and
i think they are very wise to suggest
that we roll this scheme over
and i fully supported that with the
undertaking that we would definitely
um look at having a new scheme for
2021 22 no 22-23
um i did actually say when i was asked
for my comments
that we really must ensure that we're
maximizing every opportunity to support
our constituents during these very
difficult times and making sure that
these schemes that we have are easily
accessed i did also raise the issue
and i think perhaps i didn't make it
quite clear
that we want to make sure that our
discretionary housing payment fund
which pays and helps people for paying
rent
is fully utilized and that we actually
make sure that people having hardship
paying
their rent as well as their council tax
is presented in a way that is easily
accessible i've been assured that
everyone is given this advice when
they're written to
so um i think we're trying to cover
everything
i think as councillors we must make sure
that if people approach
us that we make them aware of the
schemes that are available to them
to lend assistance so i would support
the proposals in this report i'd like to
go one further and make sure that we
encourage uh full utilization of our
discretionary housing payments
and the explanation i will give for that
is that
if we don't spend this money in any one
year
we actually get a reduced amount the
following year
so it is really vital that we make sure
that we're
utilizing it that to its fullest extent
thank you thank you are you good would
you move the recommendation
yes i will propose the recommendations
oh sorry second here uh well second
who's that councillor clark oh thank you
guys scott
okay that's good that's proposing
secondly then i don't see any more
speakers on the screen so
i'll move to the vote then
thank you chair council belton uh four
councillor brenton four councillor
bright
four councillor brown four
councillor bushby or councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hunkin
councillor dance
councillor hackett
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
for councillor hudson or
councillor hurley or councillor
hatchings
four councillor inch for
councillor james or councillor james
four councillor langford
four councillor laws or
councillor leather poor councillor locke
paul councillor mcguff or
councillor newton councillor pennington
councillor watson oh thank you that's
unanimous chair
thank you very much councillors we move
to item 10
oh sorry item 9 north devon and torres
to local plan
and uh the officer leading on that base
good evening chair uh may i introduce
myself
uh it's in roland from the planning
policy team from target to council and
i'll lead on this item if i may
so good evening to members other
officers and members of the public
i'm joined by my colleague dawn burgess
uh this evening from the policy team
and also by sean harrington who is the
newly appointed planning manager for
torridge who will be here at the end to
be able to answer any questions for you
that you may have
so i intend to provide a brief
introduction to the item
you have a detailed report before you on
pages 101-112 of your agenda
and i think that provides comprehensive
information on the basis for the
recommendations
so the purpose is to consider proposals
for a review and update of the north
dakota
local plan and what i'm seeking is
uh agreement for some high level
principles which wish
if agreed will provide us with the basis
for commencing some more detailed work
you'll be aware that the local plan
forms part of the statutory development
plan
and that's what we use for determining
planning applications
however it does a lot more than that and
it's one of the principal vehicles for
setting out how the council
and our community ambitions and the area
should develop over the coming decades
and it's about developing a vision for
the area and setting the framework for
how that'll be achieved
isn't simply a planning document but
it's a delivery vehicle for the council
the partners and other stakeholders in
in terms of achieving
their goals and our goals as a council
so you're probably quite surprised to
see this report in front of you the
existing joint local plan
was only adopted a little over two years
ago a joint meeting of north devon
council and this council
however i think you'd all agree the
world in which this plan was intended to
operate
has changed uh almost beyond what any of
us could have imagined
uh when it was being developed over the
preceding years
now preparation of a local plan is a
complex and time-consuming process and
therefore it's necessary to factor in
that
even if we start now it will be a number
of years before into a position where we
can adopt a new local plan
in the meantime we just wanted to
provide members with the reassurance
that broadly speaking
our existing adopted local plan will
provide us with a robust framework
to continue making planning decisions
until we're in a position where we can
get that
that new local plan in place so whilst
we're only required to review a local
plan every five years
members of the local planned working
group
and officers consider there's compelling
reasons
why there's a sense to embark on that
journey now
not least it's been identified as an
action in our strategic
plan so equally the government has
indicated an expectation that we'll all
have an up-to-date local plan in place
by december 2023 and as it stands
there's a real possibility
that by that date we will not be able to
demonstrate that our existing local plan
is up to date
but we've got and more importantly i
think a real
changing agenda and context both locally
and nationally the green agenda
that certainly our council has declared
a climate emergency
we've got environmental emergencies at
the national level the 25 year
environment plan
we've got changes of attitudes and
opportunities for the environment
towards transport and renewables but the
impacts of coastal change that we're all
too aware of
um we've got a renewed direction for
what the council wishes to achieve
some of which comes out of that and
that's set out in our strategic plan
we've got an evolution of our town
centres which we're working on changing
working patterns lifestyle choices and
migration
a lot of which is accelerated by covid
we've got
challenges to our housing supply and
demonstrating that but also
affordability
of housing for for our local communities
and we got a reflection on the role of
rural areas and the concepts of
sustainability in those areas
and agricultural reform coming out of
brexit etc
i could go on and we've also got council
planning reforms
um council planning forms and government
planning reforms
uh coming forward although we don't know
the specific consequences
of those and the timings are a little
unknown at the moment
you'll all remember the white paper
reports that we had back along a number
of months ago
so the plan review provides the
opportunity to consider how development
of the area should respond to these
issues
whilst it might not provide us with all
of the answers or be able to deliver
everything everybody wants
it provides us with the opportunity to
explore and develop solutions to some of
those things
so whilst there's uncertainty about some
of these future planning reforms and the
wider context
is considered that with careful planning
we can consider
and minimize the risk of abortive work
and get a head start
should some of those planning reforms
come forward
local plan working group have considered
the notion of a plan review
over the past year or so and have backed
the recommendations that you see before
you this evening at their meeting in
august
northampton and forage local plan was
the product of a successful partnership
with
north devon council and it's recommended
that any review and
update is completed in partnership with
north devon council once more
as set out in the report this brings
significant benefits both to the
councils
and to our communities due to the timing
of the meeting
cycles northern council considered a
similar report
to this at their full council at the
beginning of the month
whereby they endorsed a parallel set of
recommendations
this evening i seek a agreement of a
high set of high-level principles to
allow the substantive work to begin
to continue to work in partnership with
north devon council on plan making
recognizing those benefits efficiency
sharing of resources
a holistic strategy for northern devon
whilst allowing
locally specific and responsive
approaches to torridge and some of our
communities more locally
given the scope of the issues discussed
it's also to commit to the comprehensive
review and update of the local
plan recognize it likely provides the
only opportunity to address the broad
range of issues that are identified
you'll see your recommendations also
suggest that carrying out a full scoping
exercise to establish the full detailed
work program and the likely resource
requirements
and to update our local development
scheme which is the formal program for
plan preparation
and that would come back should these
recommendations pass
to a future meeting of this council or
possibly community and resources
so also to review the governance
arrangements for the preparation the
plan local planner working group is is
hugely effective
but we need to be making sure that we're
efficient
and providing effective oversight and
screening scrutiny and engagement
going forward and the final
recommendation
is to look for some early engagement
workshops for members to identify key
issues and some ideas for some solutions
the report sets out details of the
resource and financial implications of
this
along with potential risk management i
would direct you to
the recommendations on page 111 of your
agenda and i'd hand back to the chair at
this point
and that myself and other colleagues are
available and happy to field questions
and i'll point out that i believe
council hicks chair of the local plan
working group may wish to say a few
words thank you chair
thank you thank you ian uh first on to
speak is
counselor newton
uh thank you chair uh i was going to uh
thank him for his succinct
uh summary of what is a huge subject uh
that we all know
and i was going to go straight to
recommending that uh
we accept all five recommendations
in the office report on page 111 thank
you
thank you councillor newton i have a
second her please yes i'll second that
council look
thank you councillor lock okay so now
councillor hicks
thank you mr chairman um i've sat on
this committee for many years
currently i'm landed with the job of
chairman of it
i go right back to 1999 when torrids
produced a local plan
which was an awful problem to the
council for many years
because it was over restrictive
and we're still suffering from that in
some respect
because the lack of the five-year land
supply is related to
the fact that that plan didn't release
land
two years no 12 months ago we did
introduce a new local plan
which does ease the problems and
is a better document but it is
far far from perfect
that to be perfectly honest we're
already finding
big flaws in it particularly in some of
the smaller rural areas
um and related to many other things
the recommendation that's put forward
here
is to be quite blunt the only way in
which the council can go
working with north devon means that we
can utilize their officers they can
utilize
ours and we don't get duplication of
reports
one set of officers work on one part of
the local plan
another set works on another part
so it's got to be cost effective
there's going to be an awful lot of work
associated with it
we've got to work out how we're going to
do it bearing in mind
that our last local plan took from 19
until no
from nine until 19 and we're looking to
get this next one done in something like
three years so there's going to be an
awful lot of work we're going to have to
be prepared to invest
money in it in staff and time of members
members are going to have to have a lot
more input because it comes clear
from the government white paper
that local input is going to be
needed um i just
i'm grateful that we've already got
someone moving the recommendation and
someone
seconding it and we really have no
alternatives
thank you thank you councillor hicks
councillor haynes is next to speak
um yes thank you very much to ian roland
and
um for introducing this document um
as lead member i'm very pleased that
climate
um the climate emergency has been
recognised and
that there need to be much stronger
policies incorporated in the local plan
and also on biodiversity um
regarding council import i was
interested to see a phrase
under 232 or sent mention of
uh further of involvement of
councillors on the local plan working
group
i don't think that has been taken up by
councillors very much and
i look forward to being able to go along
to working group meetings
to provide some hopefully input um i'd
also like to
just raise the question of the schle
process of strategic housing land
allocation which
i don't know if it's ever been looked at
but when when we looked at it at
northern town council a few years ago it
appeared that
there's not much public input into the
process of
allocating land or um
it seems to be a process which could do
with widening out
and uh the question of public engagement
and local plan
i think it's very important that
the whole question of public engagement
is looked at again because
it's quite obvious particularly well
where i
represent appledore that a lot of people
don't feel they were involved in the
local plan process and we need to look
very carefully at making sure they are
the question of viability i think
council christie and others have raised
this
the whole thing of assessing viability
and providing affordable housing needs
to be strongly looked at
again and policies reflecting that and
also of course
about the whole question of affordable
housing and social housing in particular
which seems to me the one of the routes
we should be going on
if we're ever going to provide housing
for people
who can't afford to purchase um
finally can we just i think it was
referenced by councillor hicks to the
five-year allocation
can can we just be told what the
president's situation is about that
where we are on the five-year allocation
please
thank you do we have to answer that
question or no
yeah chair if i may i can certainly come
back on on a number of those points
uh in in terms of input and for from
members i
think certainly we would be wanting to
to engage
the the wider membership of the council
actively uh throughout the process um
members may recall not many members are
probably involved but certainly in the
early days of local plan preparation
last time around there was
there was a huge amount of participation
in workshops and town
visioning exercises rule workshops etc i
i think it's the
the duration of plan preparation time
last time that
that was the real problem there and and
made a feeling of a lack of engagement
through it but
certainly we're fully on board with
needing to engage members not only from
the local planned working group
but across the the broad spectrum of the
whole council
and and the same with public engagement
is exactly the same
in terms of the schla that is a
technical
exercise in terms of that what it
doesn't do
is allocate the sites and that is a an
exercise
for members based upon the evidence of
the schla
and the evidence of other documents and
technical studies that we prepare
um so i think we need to make sure that
we we understand the separation of those
two exercises
there it's not meant to be a black box
in terms of of the schla
but it is a a technical exercise rather
than a choice exercise
and that comes at a different part of
the plan making
i totally agree in terms of the issues
around viability affordable housing
they're just two of the issues that
we've got to try and tackle as we move
forward
in terms of the five-year housing land
supply we are still in the same
situation
as under um the outcome of the burwood
decision
under the covered and coronavirus on the
lockdown
it's not really been possible to
get to a position where we'd be able to
demonstrate that five year housing land
supply again at the moment
it's certainly something that we will be
revisiting next year
to see whether or not we are in a
position to be able to reestablish that
but it is resource intensive and we need
to balance that against our plan
preparation as well
okay thank you councillor christie you
had your hand raised
thanks for christine yeah thank you i i
lost it for a while there i lost the
internet
um can i ask a question that uh recently
we heard that there were problems with
torridge's um searches
they were taking quite a long time and
that was partly due to staff but also
partly due to the sheer
volume um and i've raised this issue
i've talked to a couple of
local surveyors where people are
literally buying houses off the internet
without even seeing them in our area and
there seems to be this huge demand
partly because of cobit partly as
the internet gets better for houses in
this area
so when we look at this uh local plan
can we try and strengthen up
enormously uh the allowance for
local people and affordable homes
because otherwise
we are just going to get swamped by
people from the cities
no problem with that in the sense that
these will be
they'll be bringing a high-tech job to
them hopefully but
we really need to take this on board
that suddenly we have become
a target area just from our rurality and
it's something i don't think has been
allowed for in the last local plan
um certainly all of us will know the
problems
uh with affordable houses in our areas
and the lack of infrastructure
and i think this is something the local
plan really does
need to look at now i got to apologize
if this is already being brought up
but in paragraph 2.5
on page 102 it's very carefully worded i
love the way the officers
put this at this stage there is
significant
uncertainty as to when the government
are likely to
introduce the planning reforms given
that there seems to be a conservative
backlash from all their councillors
um do we know if this is that's my cat's
tail away even
um does it has there been any update on
this
is it gonna happen or not have we had
any um
indication of that at all you answer
that one ian
yeah certainly i can come back on that
um in inten i'll answer the last part
first
in terms of the planning reforms i think
no we're none the wiser in terms of
the the specifics now all the messages
we get
from uh the chief planning officer
ministry of housing
local government is certainly that they
are intent on progressing forward with
the
proposals or at least the high level
principles of those proposals
um but but as as councillor christie
said we we've all seen
the the news reports of the backlash
that he's coming
from some of these proposals i think
what i would say is that
our way forward we would look to be
getting ourselves prepared to be able to
accommodate
those proposed reforms whilst making
sure that we were still fully compliant
with the approach that's that's there
now um so certainly we would be looking
to
prioritize and program work so that it
wouldn't be abortive
as we would go forward and make sure
that we had an
eye to how that may need to be taken
forward
should those planning reforms come in
and certainly in terms of affordability
and housing
i think we all appreciate that and
certainly it's one area we need to look
at it's a real challenging issue
um we all know that development
viability is
is problematic and often is cited by
developers
we need to explore that and see how we
can maximize the delivery of affordable
housing but
also improve affordability more widely
thank you council james is next thank
you chair
um just a couple of things i was going
to agree with in there
i've been involved in discussions where
they know talking about the planning
reforms
maybe not quite what we've been told and
that we're not likely to see them till
the spring at the very earliest
so um that's a little way off in terms
of local housing and affordable housing
we've already started a a scoping
exercise to find out what other councils
are doing
so that we can as part of our strategic
plan there is talk of
us providing our own hosting and looking
how we're going to do it
and so we've actually started a scoping
exercise
talking to other councils to see what
they're doing um i've
regularly talked to cornwood about what
they're doing i've got a good idea what
they're doing
but we are looking at what other
councils are doing um to see whether
there's anything we can adopt or any way
forward on that
and that will come back once we've got
something to report
thank you chair thank you very much
councillor bushby
thank you chairman um page 104
down at the bottom um paragraph 2.19
219.
um i don't know whether it was a
contradiction or whether i'm just not
reading it correctly but um
if you read that that paragraph where it
states a further alternative would be a
separate development plan
document to provide additional climate
change policies
alongside those on the local plan whilst
this approach may be
able to contribute to addressing the
declared climate and biodiversity
emergencies
it would not address wider issues
equally the scope for potential change
or additions to policy
to address these matters is again likely
to be extremely limited due to the need
to not adversely affect the viability of
development
for example it would be unlikely to be
possible
to require solar panels or new dwellings
it would also not allow the councils
to position itself effectively to take
kind of the proposed planning reforms
as such the officers do not recommend
this course of action so
that part of it all the officers saying
they want to strike that out they don't
want that in the in the new plan
yeah for me certainly i understand
that's a bit of a mouthful in terms of
that paragraph
and i i apologize for that certainly
that's not the intent there
what it's saying is that instead of a
comprehensive review of the local an
update of the
the whole local plan we could possibly
prepare
uh effectively a supplement to it on
just climate change
so it would be additional policies
alongside our existing local plan for
climate change
however there's real difficulties in
doing that as it says there because
as soon as you start adjusting or
wanting more out of the development on
things such as
solar panels or wind turbines within a
micro turbines within a development or
something like that it impacts viability
and then it has a kick kick forward in
terms of a knock on
in terms of some of our other policies
and we would need to review
for example if we wanted to do that we'd
need to review the likes of our
affordable housing policy because our 30
may not be viable anymore so
it's it's effectively saying that we
probably wouldn't get out of it what we
would want
if we were to look down the route of
just preparing a supplement
can i come back on my chair please all
right
thank you well
i'm as a job to know exactly where we're
coming from with this because
you know torres uh district uh along
with devon county and indeed along with
the government
we've all declared climate uh
emergencies
now if we're really serious about this
you know we need to be we need to be um
imposing conditions on new developments
for example dad and hill
large developments of that nature
whereby
we insist or it should be a condition of
the planning
that any of these developments they have
to
plan for the very latest and the very
most
up-to-date insulation
um you know anything where they can save
energy
you know ground source heat pumps but
you know things like
um panels on the roof to actually you
know absorb energy from
that that's not new that's been around
for years and years i just can't
understand
why in this day and age where you've got
all these emergencies being um being
recorded
and and you know we're gonna we promise
that the
the public at large you know we're gonna
take this seriously
why something like that cannot be
included
in a local plan i i take the point of
you know
you make it um the more
complex and more expensive you make some
of these things it makes
it makes it less attractive for a
developer
to be you know to to actually develop a
site but if you're talking about putting
solar panels on a roof
on a on 500 hoses you know the economies
of scale kick in here
it can't be that expensive and at the
end of the day these you know these
costs are passed on to the consumer to
the processor anyway
all right maybe it's a response to that
in or yeah i i wholeheartedly agree with
councillor bushby
um i think our existing local plan goes
as far as it was able at the time and
actually is is one of the
the most uh advanced of its time in
terms of
some of these these climate change
elements in terms of things like
biodiversity net gain
um our approach to flood risk et cetera
uh there's a lot in the existing local
plan i think we were frustrated by the
timings really with our local plan
we had hoped for example to be
introducing zero carbon homes in 2016
through the code for sustainable homes
and during the plan preparation there
there were changes
in the way the government approached
that and told us we weren't able at that
point in time
to go beyond what they established in
building regulations
now we're in a different place now and
certainly i think one of the things with
being able to look at this holistically
through a
comprehensive local plan review is that
opportunity to
to really look at how we prioritize
these things what's important to us
locally
and and to try and be innovative and
creative around that
as i said we're not going to be able to
deliver everything and there will be
choices to be made
but by looking at it collectively and
through a comprehensive review it gives
us that option to really be creative
right okay thank you pastor ford
hello chair can you hear me yes thank
you
well i just indulged me for a couple
minutes if you don't mind
um i'm not going to go at the officers
doing a report one
one thing another but here we are again
really just being led by the nose
and just a few observations that i feel
strongly about
i do believe that joint and severally
over the last 30 to 40 years we as
individuals counsellors and other bodies
have done a good job of ruining our
environment
and on record i've asked this before and
i like it minutes now
when we talk about climate change etc
we've just recently passed the visitors
center
which is technically in my award which
i'm totally against not the visitor
center but where it is
and anybody can guarantee that for 30 or
40 years is a joke
but not not one that i'm actually
laughing at if we go back in time i
think you'll find pre-1962
with land sales you could actually have
a claw off
um no we are dealt with we've got 106
flimsy agreements it's
not honored and it's all to do with
viability which is a joke
quite frankly again one i'm not laughing
about
basically to me we ought to be
going back to pre-62 where actually it's
just because somebody's got some
agricultural land that wants to make a
millionaire too we should actually have
a direct claw off
at source in fact sometimes perhaps what
they've completely purchased that i've
never seen used for ages
then another observation very often that
i've even come across on a recent thing
at sorry
you know we have councillors which i
know it's difficult but we have
councillors making decisions
on settlements they don't even know
haven't even visited
you know it's i mean appledore it's just
again which is not untypical but you
can't even get through that i'm glad i
got a motorbike because i need it
motorbike to push bike you still get
around but don't try driving a car
perhaps you seriously look at self
builds land trust or whatever because we
talk about it for the world and it ain't
happening it ain't going out
and basically again repeat what i said
we're just being led by
those are bullied here by central
government and policies
and quite frankly what should have
happened i know hindsight is a wonderful
thing
and i know boris keeps on about mr
kierskarma being uh captain hindsight
well
i don't know what i'm i'm cutting on so
i've been saying this for 30 years mate
i'm sorry about the language but quite
frankly
you know we should have had a bit of
forward thinking actually if we
as council chris is absolutely right
there's more and more demand here but
you've been far
better you've almost created like at
least like you did years ago
like milton kingston new towns and
villages
near a proper role done properly rather
than keep adding on to stuff that was
built for horse and car
with that i'll leave it but i'm not a
happy bunny and i won't be supporting
this
on principle thank you very much eric
cancer ford
councillor lock is next yeah just a
quick question
for ian coming back on the five-year
land supply
i know we can't we haven't got the
five-year land supply but
i couldn't recollect quite recently the
plans committee
paperwork it was quoted that we got 4.85
years is that correct
um um and council lock no
um unfortunately it's 4.23 years is
still
our established published position in
terms of our housing land supply
and until we're able to provide an
update which involves
a lot of consultation with the
development industry
um engagement and understanding of their
delivery
and also an understanding of our pre our
delivery
over the past year we're not able to
update that position
um effectively so we we are
in that position for now and certainly
as i said we look to try
and review that um in the coming year
depending on priorities
and and and what members choose in terms
of workloads
that they wish to put towards us thank
you all right
thank you very much uh councilman coffin
and i'm going to go to the vote
thank you very much mr chairman this is
directed to ian
ian you say about a comprehensive view
and obviously creative style going
forward with this
uh new local plan or the amendment to
the local plan
now where i find it really hard is
obviously we need to
understand our own demographic of our
own area so would it not be beneficial
to do it or as a separate local plan for
torridge
therefore we can take control locally of
actually what's going on um and
i want to touch on the fact like corman
we keep mentioning cornwall in this
council
it's nothing to do with torridge i have
nothing to get the cornish
i do like the corners nobody's twisting
words on that we need to understand our
own demographic data
within our own areas so we can actually
understand how we can benefit the public
which is within torah's district council
it represents the torridge itself we
seem to be missing a point on the
residents of vintoridge
and you know going forward i do really
believe we need to sit down and think
really hard about this
i understand the wrong demographic area
we show economic
boost within the area or deprivation we
can actually work on this locally
i do have my reservations for this we're
going with north devon we need to
understand actually stand their own two
feet
thank you thank you guys so i'm going to
go to the vote now
um which the recommendation is on page
111
it's been proposed and seconded so uh
kirsty when you're ready
thank you chair councillor belton uh for
councillor brenton or councillor bright
bore councillor brown four
councillor bushby or
councillor christie or councillor clark
or councillor cottle hunking
four councillor dart
four councillor ford against
councillor gub paul
councillor hackett
councillor hackett
okay he's still connected but he's not
responding kirsty so
you have to make sure councillor haines
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins
or councillor hudson or
councillor hurley or
councillor hutchins
for councillor james or
councillor jones
councillor langford or
councillor laws or councillor leather
or councillor lock or
councillor mcgoff i'm against
councillor newton four
councillor pennington councillor watson
four so it's 27
four and three against chad hello it's
councillor hackett here i
i couldn't get my unmute in time could
you put me down as
four please certainly thank you
councillor okay thank you
thank you that's 28 four and three
against chair
thank you very much councillors the key
one owner's recommendation to remember
is item five
uh early member workshops so uh get
involved
um thank you jeff thank you ian
number 10 now uh resource and waste
management strategy
um which is on page 113 starting off
so uh who's leading on this
thank you chair i will thank you
uh good evening all i'm richard haste
i'm the operational services manager
and the purpose of bringing the draft
resource and waste management strategy
for devon and torbay to full council
is that devon county council require all
individual local authorities to approve
the draft strategy
so that it can go out for public
consultation
so that torridge members have the
document we can give feedback
when it does go out to public
consultation which is anticipated to be
in february 2021 and run for six weeks
and also to present the strategy to
members on how the resources and waste
is going to be managed going forward for
the next 10 years
so the strategy focuses on waste
prevention and reuse
as well as carbon impact and how waste
and recycling is collected throughout
devon and tool bay
both council leather and i attend the
devon authority's strategic waste
committee
which is made up of all waste collection
authorities seven county council and
tall bay
as stated in the report the government
published in 2018 its own waste and
resource strategy and is planning
further consultation
uh on a number of key proposals which
could impact on local authorities
on page 12 of the strategy it shows
devon's collective response to the
headline proposals
but the one that makes most impact for a
rural authority like torridge
it would be if it were to go ahead and
implement free garden waste service to
all properties which would have a
significant financial pressure on our
revenue budget
with regard to climate change high waste
is dealt with can have a significant
impact on the greenhouse gases which
contribute to about four percent
nationally of which three percent is
waste center landfill
you'll be pleased to know that devon no
longer sends any curbside collected
waste to landfill
and this strategy will aim to set a path
for carbon neutrality by 2050.
well for torridge we've already made
great improvements since the service
change
with our recycling and composting rate
have an increase from 41
in 2017-18 to 54
last year first full year of the service
change
each household is also presenting 150
kilos
less waste in their black bag for the
same time period
we now provide an aligned mod we now
provide an aligned model for devon which
is weekly
recycling including food chargeable
garden waste and fortnightly residual
based
collections but authorities are already
looking to move to three weekly residual
with east devon already adopting that
method
and reaching a target of 60 which is
something that will have to be
considered by members within the period
of this strategy
torridge at the moment though we're not
in a position to consider it
until we've got an environmental center
near biddeford unless we
increase the number of vehicles to
provide the service we should not be
financially viable
or economically viable i'm not going to
any more details of taking more of your
time which is
quite a busy agenda and any feedback
can be given during the consultation
period so the recommendation is that
members be asked to approve that the
draft resources and waste management
strategy with devon
until they go out for public
consultation
happy to take any questions chair uh
thank you
uh richard well there's a whole list of
them so be ready
uh counselor answers first now thank you
chair i'll just uh
declare an interest i am a member of uh
devon county council that's all i have
to say
all right
my recommendation is that we accept this
confrontation document i
just want to mention i didn't expect in
my
agenda and pack to get the whole thing
sentenced well over a hundred pages
i really thought that um members who
wanted to look at it in depth
could have either gone online or looked
at it or asked somebody in the office to
print them off a hard copy richard
kindly
copied me off a hard copy some weeks ago
when it came out
but to send all this amount of paper
through with the agenda i think it's a
bit
ridiculous really and here we are trying
to save on waste so
well i don't think it was necessary
chair to send all this through the post
but i'm happy to commend it because it
is a very very
comprehensive document on a few on the
way forward
to 20 30 chair right so you're moving
the recommendation on page 160
yes sure i'll move the recommendation
around seconds thank you very much
uh well councillor leather gotta have
something to read over the christmas
period it's stuck at home on your own so
there you go
um who we got next cancer hudson
thank you very much chair um listening
to
richard introduced this report in saying
that we would have
ample opportunity during the
consultation period
uh to make comment on the document um
it is is great but there are a few
things before we actually recommend this
to go out to the public
that i'd like some clarification on
the document although in the
introduction refers to the fact that we
are
no longer in europe refers
in several places especially 5.2
the circular economy to us being bound
by european legislation
and uh one quick question is this tabled
to be enshrined in uk legislation
second part which richard mentioned was
the discussion about
free garden waste when we're looking at
income generation uh to meet our budget
demands next year we need to be mindful
of that
page 174 talks about commercial waste
and the fact that this is not sorted out
at the moment
one of the key things for me that i
became aware of was schools waste
that is collected by commercial bodies
and the fact that food and other
materials are all mixed in together
is this not a quick win for us within
torridge
that we could actually collect food
waste
um page 178 talks about
local no local re reprocessing in the
southwest
surely this is something we as a council
ought to be
taking forward to the left
uh to actually look at working up a bid
or something in the southwest and lastly
but not least
page 193 where all the statistics are
even though i've got all the document
there's no entry for torridge
so um perhaps i can go online and have a
look at that one
but a very thorough document but just
these
key things some that we want to be
mindful of
and one that i'd like if richard could
come back and
sorry richard i've given you a whole
quiz list here
um you could respond to please
sure thank you thank you chair so
in reverse order so we'll go to the last
yes the statistics page for torridge
uh has been addressed uh and county have
been made
uh aware of that and we'll we're going
to be updated
um with the represses reprocessors in
the southwest
well once again we have limited control
over that as a waste collection
authority and it's it's generally
actually commercial private sector but
it's economies of scale
you need to make these sites efficient
vast
you know a vast plant and at the moment
the most cost-effective route for your
big um reprocessors throughout the
country
is more in the midlands and centrally
um so once again it is economies of
scale um
schools waste we do provide a curbside
service of
the uh of recyclable material
and that's offered to all schools but it
has to be at limited
uh levels because obviously our vehicles
will fill up from a classroom
school of three four hundred people
children then
then it would uh it would fill our
vehicles up
and it's something that other collectors
do better
and cheaper to be fair um commercial
waste once again without our own
reprocessing plant
and facility um we're not set up at the
moment
coastal recycling and demo waste
management provide that service
and generally can provide just as a
competitive rate but that's something we
certainly will look at going forward
and with the eu legislation that's
referred to in the document then
i will go back to the county waste
manager um to give an update
right and to put more thank you very
much
thank you very much richard um because
i'll say we have got a long list here
uh councillor haynes if you be brief
please counsellors
um yeah this is very thorough document
with lots of interesting proposals in it
and i commend it to councillors to read
if they've got the time um the emphasis
is on
reducing carbon in line with the climate
emergency
so i would hope and urge that we
continue with our environment
center and don't as has been
hinted at reduce the amount to reduce
the investment in it when we look at our
budget
we need to consider build an environment
center that can
cover all sorts of recyclables which we
don't at the moment
so that we can reduce the residual waste
that goes to
the energy from waste plant up in
bristol wherever it is
which of course produces huge amounts of
carbon emissions into the atmosphere
and um in fact such plants are on the
increase so i gather
so i think it's very much up to us in
terms of i'm an emergency to reduce that
carbon load
thank you okay thank you uh councillor
hicks is next on the list
thank you mr chairman one very simple
question i'm curious
what would happen if this council didn't
accept the recommendation
answer
if if this council didn't accept the
recommendation for the draft report to
go at the public consultation um
then that will be a stalling block and i
think that's uh
why the report was brought forward that
all councils are required
for it to go into constant public
consultation
right so we've nearly got no alternative
have we
seemingly not no
all right thank you all right councillor
bushby next
thank you chair um richard uh
you you mentioned zero to landfill i'm
reading the
document and i think one of the previous
speakers may have already answered the
question
but when you say zero to landfill does
that apply to trade waste
as well as your private collections
thank you we don't actually provide any
trade waste collections
uh as a local authority um
when they say there is an element a
small element of waste if you look
through the document does it still go to
landfill that's
certain items such as fly-tipped
asbestos and fly-tip material that can't
go there as well as
materials that can't be recycled in the
household recycling centers
but at the moment we we we don't provide
trade selections
um but it's something that we certainly
would look at in the future
so that that's not exactly what i asked
richard
torrige your rule say collections you're
they don't go to landfill zero landfill
i see it on the trucks but all of those
trucks that i see driving around the
area that are doing
waste collection from trade sources
private companies
do do they go to landfill still
um depending on the infrastructure
they've got for
for sorting out the waste yeah an
element of it would go
but bearing in mind with the landfill
tax the most expensive form of disposal
is landfill so it'll be in their
interests as to sort it and minimize
as much as they can to go into landfill
but yes there would be
private companies can do what they wish
and how they wish to dispose of their
waste
right because i see in the report the um
413 thousand tons of household waste
in devon and torre bay annually they'll
be able 560 000 tons
of commercial waste so it's clearly the
commercial waste
is a you know it's a lot larger
operation uh in terms of you know the
the bulk um collections um
so clearly you know the the wish there
is that
if we're serious about zero to landfill
you know
we need to be putting pressure where we
can on zero to landfill
for all all waste collectors you know
private trade
as well you know probably not probably
not in our
power to do that but um i just make the
point
thank you okay thank you councilman golf
is next
thank you much mr chairman i i fully
support the increase in recycling going
forward in the future
for this document to go out as well for
the public
to have a perusal through to add their
comments to it
i fully endorse obviously the carbon
neutral going forward as a council it's
very important
obviously for the future for everybody
um but what i can't support is the
increase in the three-week bag
collection which may be coming
obviously i represent an urban ward
within biddeford town
center and we have a high number of
flats within the area
now to be honest you know we need
something a specific plan for town
centers to safeguard
obviously public health and obviously we
need to give support for residents
who don't have the option to store the
black bags i.e
if you've got small children changing
nappies etc i know a high volume of
people within the water i represent
who really really struggle at this time
because of the nappies and that's to the
waste itself and these bags get chucked
out by people
irresponsible people checking out the
town sentence itself
mr hayes can confirm uh places like butt
garner street home stone street
um just to name a few little places
that's the main
places actually we have a lot of
problems with we need really need to
tackle this before it goes to public
consultation
i think torah should have something in
we need
a plan going forward ourselves how can
we actually attack with this to actually
give
our residents who obviously has a lot of
social deprivation within the town
centers
we need to provide a safeguard for these
residents and obviously
the public health as well because
they're only going to get out of control
if we go to free weekly
collections on black bags i couldn't
support that but i fully support
the recycling and obviously the carbon
neutral aspect going forward so mr hayes
you've got a challenge
i'm more than happy to work with you to
try and give you some ideas how we can
actually tackle the town centers
thank you thank you councillor
pennington is next
uh thank you chair just a clear personal
interest i do have a landfill site on my
land that goes back some years
not sure what the status is but i wanted
to ask a question on page 174 about
landfill redundant
i'm not quite understanding what the
paragraph means devon has a historic
legacy of sending residual waste to
landfill
and has some degree of responsibility
for the 58 sites closed across the
country
across the county um what about the
barriers down there is
are they washing our hands of the
boroughs if we agree to this package
tonight
what is their responsibility towards um
the uh landfill site down there um
um surely they've got full
responsibility have they not can you
explain to me richard and thank you for
all your good work this year
well we're not making a decision in our
council repentance is for to go into
public consultation really
so however um richard
yeah thank you coachella pennington i i
don't think this document
this draft document has as any bearing
on their responsibility regarding
the landfill sites including northern
boroughs i think the responsibility
does not change um this is how waste is
managed going forward and the future of
how it's going to be collected
and processed and dealt with so i don't
i don't think it has anything to do with
um the old sites of which they would
still have a responsibility for
they will still have the responsibility
richard will they
i as far as i'm aware unless stacy or
or sean has any other different opinion
on this thank you
right okay so i've got um cancer
christie i think is um
having trouble with this um technology
tonight um but i think he had his
hand up earlier on is that right
councillor christie i did
i've only just come back on i'm not sure
what's happening it's obviously bill
gates is getting at me
no no we've had a bunch of no confidence
in you that's all so don't worry about
it
um there's a couple of things uh
councillor haines touched on the idea of
um the incinerators up in bristol
and i do find it odd that we're going
for net zero
carbon and yet we're still burning all
this stuff um can i ask however that
there's a lot of
cynicism out there what happens to our
recyclables
i meet people say oh it's not bothering
they just burn it or they just throw
they just add it to everything else
could torridge send out a leaflet with
our next council tax demand or something
just saying where it goes i know
it has been done before but it does need
to be addressed i think because
if people don't believe their recycle
their recyclables are actually being
recycled they won't bother
um and there is a lot of cynicism out
there
um can i just refer to one thing i do
apologize if this has been brought up
on page 129
there's a um a list of government
proposals and devon's position
and i the the one that i was amazed at
is one two three four five six one down
deposit return
scheme now looking at most of the
councils they can probably all remember
when you know you've got threatens back
on your corona bottle and all that sort
of thing
if you've been to europe you've seen in
the supermarkets this works
this system and i i'm amazed that
devon doesn't seem to be you know on
board with this
and i really cannot understand why
because it would be the supermarkets who
do it
not us as such and i think we should
look again at that
and on page 130 i notice there is um
devon districts talk about um
[Music]
employing uh people um
i don't know if we've employed anyone
yet uh
and the last one and the one that again
may
well have been referred to before so i
do apologize it's about the landfill
sites
because on page 174 um you've got
a section there on landfill redundant
landfill sites and of course everyone
immediately thinks of westwood ho
um it talks about what they've done with
them
and if you look on page 191
uh it's even better it's a very short
thing redundant landfill sites
to continue to maintain and monitor
closed landfill sites to ensure their
impact on the environment is minimized
achieved well i'm glad we're still
watching them
um no suggestions as to what to do with
that and i find that a bit odd and i
would like
uh to go back to a suggestion i made
some time ago that
all those interested in that landfill
and northern boroughs
all the people interested get together
and try and
hammer some sort of policy out because
we do seem to be talking
in little groups and nobody seems to
really get to grips with this
and so i think we should thank you right
well this is going out to public
consultation and some good ideas have
come up tonight so i'm hoping that their
counselors will
put their input into this public
consultation so that um
it they can put a good report out when
we
come to approve it in the end councillor
four is going to be the last one and
then i'm going to go to the vote then
mr ford yeah thanks chair uh just uh
general observations here um
obviously very extensive report um
as council of penta that you know i said
there you know uh
thanks for the effort put in there
there's a few things i just like
to generalize on which is very important
actually
is we shouldn't just be here seeing how
great
the officers are done it's actually the
frontline staff actually
what matters and our service is only as
good as a frontline staff to be fair and
i think we're all doing difficult times
all um perhaps even give them a round of
applause and pat them on the back
i think they've done a great job and
going forward
it's important that we take the staff
with us
so what i would say and i'd also like to
say to the head of paid services i want
to make sure that the staff
are actually consulted as well and
even if they could have a suggestion
boxes
anonymous because sometimes the staff
can actually come forward with some good
good ideas because sometimes i've
reflected it's a bit concerning but
perhaps it isn't particularly our eye
but i do read the papers
as regards civil enforcement officers as
i've mentioned on another issue but also
as regards
staff in recycling and waste there
seemed to be a reasonable turnover
and picking up what councilman golf said
uh and he's absolutely right we all got
our problems and our obviously highlight
appledore
especially in the summer with seagulls
and actually what i would say
is abu dharr now is and i accept that
we are very much a tourist area but we
have got
a real big problem as you guys refused
and uh
bags being whipped already it's that's
some
absolutely mess and what i've been
saying for years what is annoying to me
these holiday homes are technically a
business so really it should be trade
waste
but anyway with that i'll leave it thank
you well councillor hurley you've
managed to hit the button just as i was
saying about you
because before being the last speaker
but in fact you're going to be the last
speaker
thank you thank you very briefly cancer
christie touched on a point
page one two nine six one down deposit
return scheme
and the other the answer to that is in
the devon position
where the initiative could reduce the
devin recycling rate by
0.7 percent i think it's mainly concern
about how
uh councils actually reach the 60
percent or whatever we're supposed to
reach by 20
thirty five point seven percent may not
sound a lot but it might just be the
last
tipping point if you like to reach that
sixty percent
thank you chad thank you right so
now we've gotta go to the vote so uh
kirsty if you're ready you've got the
recommendation which is on uh page 116
that this
goes out this draft goes out for a
public consultation
thank you chair councillor belton for
councillor brenton four councillor
bright
bore councillor brown borah
councillor bushby or captain christie
or councillor clark oh
kids
or councillor hawkins or
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
against councillor hudson
or councillor hurley or
councillor hutchings or councillor h
or councilman james
or jones
or councillor langford for
counselor laws or counselor leather
or council lock or
councilman goff four
councillor newton four
chancellor pennington or councillor
watson
four so that's 34
and one against chair thank you very
much kirsty
so now we move on to uh item 11
strategic
plan leading on
this is just this is just for noting
this is there not
no vote taking on this hi church john
walter
thank you john yeah chad just passed you
over to um
councillor james the leader of the
council please um
who said he would um take this uh item
for me
thank you john um right okay councillors
you you recall that back on our meeting
of october the fifth um we had collected
up all the
replies from the strategic plan and they
were just sort of a list of what was
um uh people had responded to so we took
all the list of all the um
questions recommendations and that we've
tabulated it into the
the charts that you've had
and also we've put
allocated it or answered the questions
to either departments that can answer it
and there's obviously some in planning
some in the environment section there's
some like devon county of which perhaps
we will just reply or send a letter to
german county although
there will be some we can do nothing
about so basically what we're
doing tonight is just simply showing you
the list and the
the um the replies and where they will
be allocated
the next move will be for the the
managers
and the lead members to get together
take out their sections and come back at
later date on what progress we can make
on
um fulfilling the ambitions of people
who've made contributions
to our strategic plan um so
it's a little lucky it's not a vote one
it's only a note one
um so later date you will get um
an update of what ones are being dealt
with and how they're being dealt with
and then again it will be for members to
comment and if they want to
to forward them to john walter um and
i'll just clarify a bit on the
affordable housing side which is in the
strategic plan
where we've been asked to investigate
ways of providing affordable housing
and what we're doing is looking at other
councils because
it's something i do know a little bit
about and we're just looking at
what other councils are doing there is a
move nationwide to
try and go back to providing housing and
that can be clts it can be
um council um
host associations or it can be um as
some councils are actually
borrowing huge amounts of money to build
their own uh
old council houses in effect so on this
report is simply to note that
it will move forward to managers and to
lead members
and we will come back with a progress
report here later today
all i've got chair thank you very much
well as to say it is
just for noting really so uh you can
move on to the next item
which is a council tax base
is two three six
onwards so who's doing that finance
manager please
yes al thank you chair um the report
that's in your park
was um actually has been tabled i think
on wednesday you would have had it
circulated by mary richards
and i'll just explain the council tax
base is actually a very technical report
were required by law to produce a
council tax base to the 31st of january
um unfortunately the timetable of the
full council meetings doesn't facilitate
us having the figures
in advance of the meeting that's why
they've been tabled on wednesday
what the council tax base is it takes
our number of properties that are
eligible for council tax within the
council area converts them after various
things such as banding appeals
discounts which are single persons
discount the cost of
local council chat support and converts
that into a band d equivalent
we then share this information should
the full council approve it tonight with
our preceptors and our town and parish
councils and that gives them the base
of to know how much council tax they can
raise in the next financial year
um so the key point to note is actually
this year's for the first year since
certainly i've been at torrance district
council that the council tax base has
declined
and there's two primary reasons for that
one primarily is the shutdown in the new
build of properties that took place at
the first lockdown into potentially
april may june and into july
and the second reason is our collection
rate for council tax has reduced
from 99 percent to 97.4
for five percent reflecting the
difficulty people have had maybe paying
their
council tax as a result of furloughing
the global pandemic
so what we're seeking is approval of the
council tax base which for which for
2021 22 which is 24 035
properties um
appendix one lists that tax base by the
various town and paris councils
so i haven't really got anything more to
say
on the report more than happy to take
any questions should members have any
questions
well there shouldn't be any questions
really is a technicality as you say
isn't it so
uh okay so are there any questions if
not i'll move to the vote
no okay so i'm from the chair i'll move
the vote
uh as um move the recommendation as on
two three sorry i'll second that
thank you very much awesome so um
christy would go to the vote then
thank you chair councillor belton uh for
councillor brenton or councillor bright
for councillor brown for
councillor bushby or councillor christie
or councillor clark four
councillor cottle hunking uh
councillor dart for
councillor ford four councillor dub
four councillor hackett
he's stupid
councillor harding or councillor hawkins
for councillor heppel
for councillor hicks for
councillor hudson or councillor hurley
or councillor hutchings or
councillor inch for councillor james
or councillor jones
four pinky councillor langford
four councillor laws or
councillor leather or councillor locke
or councillor mcgruff four
councillor newton paul
councillor pennington yeah
councillor watson
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you very much kirsty
so move on to item 13 mid-year year
treasury management report this is
another report for noting
no no vote required so um let me see
who's
leading on that one is that um david
again yes it is chair thank you
thank you uh again somewhat of a
technical nature
um the council adopted the sit for
colder practice for treasury management
and the report lays out sets out the
performance for the current financial
year the 2020-21
and some key points to note needless to
say treasury management's been somewhat
interesting because of the kovid
pandemic so i'll highlight some of the
key
points in the report our average rate of
return and our short-term treasury
deposits
has declined to 0.26 percent from 1.05
percent that we were getting in 2019-20
and this is reflecting of course the
bank of england base rate cut
consequently our income that we expect
to achieve from our treasury management
deposits is will decline
in 2020 21 compared with 2021 22
from 200 sorry we're going to get a 41
000 compared to 115 000 that we received
in the previous financial year
at this point in time the council has
unusually high
levels of monies on short depos
short-term deposits
this is because we've had received
various tranches of government funding
relating to the kovid pandemic
particular in respect
of the support to businesses in terms of
the business support grants and the
local research and support grants
and we're actually expecting at some
point that
central government will reclaim seven
million pounds from us
for business support grant funding that
we receive in excess of what we've
actually paid over
um the council has actually breached its
um
counterparty limits that we have with
our various financial um
institutions we have a limit of eight
million pounds that we should have we've
lloyd at any one times with our bankers
and we
we pay our preceptors about five million
pounds every month so that's why we have
that limit
but because of the money that was really
holding on behalf of the government
at the moment and the extra funding we
keep receiving we've actually breached
that we've got more than that
um counterparty limit we've lied but
this has previously been reported to
members
um and no new borrowing has been
undertaken during the course of
2020 21. i don't anticipate um taking
out any new borrowing this year
as i said i'm more than happy to take
any questions i mean the report is just
for notice just to
try to explain to members that uh it's
been somewhat of an unusual year in
respect to our treasury management
primary well excluded because of the
covered pandemic and the government's
response to it
thank you that's that's an
understatement david there you go
any uh any comments or uh questions
shouldn't be any
otherwise we'll move on because it is
just for noting it's a midterm
report no senior hands okay thank you
oh hello got my hand up who's that oh i
didn't see that hang on
all right hi oh yeah thank you pardon
counselor haynes sorry
sorry it's just probably a naive
question but soon this is just a
statement of current situation
and yes preclude changing to possibly
sustainable investments
no that will come again and we'll have
to formally change the policy
yeah are you referring to the um
sustainable treasury deposits
council james yes yeah yeah thank you
all right oh
also cancer hicks i see your hand
thank you mr chairman i'm beginning to
wonder what the point of
the maximum holding per counter party
is when we breach it there are other
banks out there
you know we could have put it with a
number of banks i just
don't understand that the lloyds are not
the safest
no can i just um just explain because
loads of our actual bank is our current
account bank because that's how we pay
our
salaries our creditors etc the
government central government actually
has access to our bank account so they
say for example they take money out of
our bank account for their share of
business rates
the difficulty we've got at the moment
is we believe we've got
well we know we've got in excess of
seven million pounds more of business
support grants that they originally gave
us
which they are due back to central
government now they could
reclaim that money at quite short notice
that's why we've kept it
within our current account or with our
um
on short-term 32-day notice accounts
you you're correct we could uh we and we
do look at other banks
to invest our money we've got a fairly
limited range of banks we can invest in
because our treasury management deposit
says it's got to be uk registered
and fitch one rated where i'll take your
point
that we've got more money now with
lloyds and our counterparty limit of
eight million pounds
well essentially one sorry councilx
it wasn't many years ago and you were
limited to something like two million
yeah correct we changed i think two
years ago
right okay so
that report is noted then thank you
david
so we now move on to item
14 uh request
a hundred thousand loan from atlantic
record center we've got a
report in front of you and the
recommendation which is on page
250. so
lined up so far cancer pennington
followed by councillor langford
just a personal interest son is a member
of arc
right okay uh councillor langford
i want somebody to move this uh and
second it if we would please
i'm happy to do that thank you
right okay so councillor langford you're
a next one to speak
thank you um thank you chair thank you
to the officers for the report and the
time taken to meet with the art
representatives and look into all their
submissions
um i'd also like to recognize the vision
and driver for people who've initiated
and steered the art development it's a
fantastic facility
which torridge is so lucky to have i
don't want to waste time repeating
things you've heard before
i just want to reiterate how important i
think it is to support
this i feel particularly at this
difficult time we need to embrace what
we already have in charge protect it
and develop it i appreciate completely
the concerns over the money but i'm sure
the officers can explain better than me
if i've understood correctly the money
loan will not detract from other needs
or projects
it is a loan and it will be repaid
hopefully sooner than the planned term
if the 106 money comes in
i can only ask for your support for the
health and well-being of the residents
of torridge
and i'm not sure who's proposed it but
i'm i'm very keen to propose that we
accept the recommendations in full
thank you very much thank you very much
you did yeah
and it was seconded by i forget who
seconded it
next i have my hand up second
councillor bishop second
just as lead member for community
culture and leisure i wanted to second
it but
councillor bushby got there first well
if i don't mind
withdrawing mine if you prefer
i want to give it my support okay thanks
for that uh councillor laws
do you have your hand up no
yep sorry about that um yeah i totally
support it but i need some
clarification uh just on the finances
because
um dan hill uh the
the the whole project of downhill has
been broken into sections
um can the officers explain
when the 106 will be received shall we
say
that this whole development takes
10 years at what point
does the money come back to torridge by
the way of the 106
does it come back in one lump at the end
or is it
stage payments and given the the rate
of the uh the loan uh
will torridge actually be out of pocket
if it takes
10 years for the money to come back in
but i do totally support
but i just like to have clarification
and it's public monies we're using isn't
it
yeah okay uh officer can do that uh sean
yes chair i can do that one for you it's
um it's on occupation in 151st
dwelling that would be paid for some
um and in terms of being out of pocket i
i don't know i don't think so that's a
question for david but i'm not i don't
think we will be
sorry 150 first one five one
will that fall into the second phase
yes right thank you
right okay thank you for that council
mcgoff
check can i just come back and david
hayes explains
whether the books will balance yes i
mean we will be take
we're going to loan um the atlantic
racket 100 000 pound and then charge
them the interest rate that we would
be charged if we took that loan out
ourselves from the public works loan
board so
it's a one-for-one relationship in terms
of the cost that we would incur
versus the cost that they would pay in
reality
depending on the timing of these things
it we would
maybe be funding it just from working
capital as i just alluded to we actually
only get an
underlying interest rate of 0.26
so you you know technically you might
makes could argue we're actually making
some money on it
but let's just keep it simple if we were
to borrow that money
from the public works loan board we'd be
charging the same rate to the
atlantic racket thank you
all right thank you my counselor
mcgothan
very very much mr chairman yeah i'm in
full support of this motion by council
langford i'm very happy to support it uh
obviously the 106 money is obviously
being allocated for their funding
although it's quite a few years away
from fruition um
it's the last piece of the jigsaw for
him
so it needs needs to be put together
they've raised so much money which has
swayed my opinion of the racket center
what a fantastic facility
and it's obviously for you know um
touchback and casual laws but the money
side of things
you can't put a price on happiness and
well-being
and actually a healthy community you
know with what they do with any
community council laws
supersedes any money that we can put in
any pot altogether in the long run it
saves us money
within torres residents going to
obviously the doctor surgeries
for more medication a healthier place
all together but i fully support it
what a great facility the last piece
they need
the money's there the 106 is there i i
give it 150 first dwelling
obviously before it comes to torridge
but it's sort of safeguarded money's
there in the future for us so
i think torah's been very
forward-thinking and actually working
together with the community so thank you
very much
thank you councillor ford and then i'm
going to go to the vote
uh thanks cheer a couple questions i
like
answered actually because um this has
been going on quite a
while and yeah social game is important
but also
nothing comes it you know you can't have
a blank checkbook everything you know
financial costs gotta
you gotta be seen as its taxpayers money
um to get a decent social game which i'm
not doubting but
let's just keep this as brief as
possible could some
officer tell me what they actually got
for their original site at westwood
oh much from torridge as we actually
already
placed them in the past and what was
said and what was agreed at the time
and have we always have we always
historically got
every loan back that we've made because
to me
anything comes with a gamble thank you
if i left some answers on that please
i must say that's a that's a very
comprehensive question counselor forward
i'm sure well officers yeah but we are
actually talking about a hundred
thousand pound taxpayers money
and actually we're duty we're duty-bound
we have all evidence in front of us
yeah all right well sean is there any
can you answer any of that uh sure
so i can come back on part of it i don't
know how much they made for the land in
westwood hope but i do know that the
receipt
has been played back into the delivery
of the new center
that i'm sure that has been reported
before though because we went through
the things quite forensically
i just don't have that to hand we have
again i can't give you the exact sum but
we have given
the atlantic racket center several
grants from the new home to a couple of
grants i think from the new homes bonus
scheme in the past and several
councillors have supported the
um the atlanta records through
councillor grants
but i can't give you the exact figures
of those and have we been repaid on all
loans we've ever given the answers no
um i can think of uh several small
business loans that were written off in
the past
there is a risk associated with loan
giving obviously and there's a risk with
taking out a loan equally but
with the risks have been measured and
this one david's been through everything
with the atlantic racket center to look
at whether they have the ability to meet
the loan repayments
even if the section 106 weren't to come
in that was obviously
one particular thing that needed to be
considered and
is happy that they are able to meet the
loan repayments so that risk is managed
thank you thank you sean well this we
have been debating this for some
months many months and the
recommendation is on page 250
and i'm going to the vote now it's been
proposed and seconded so uh
kirsty thank you chair councillor belton
uh for councillor brenton four
councillor bright for councillor brown
boy councillor bushby or
councillor christie oh that's the clerk
for hustler cottle hankin for
that's the dart
four councillor hawkins or
that's the happle or that's the hicks
against new york
councillor hudson oh
councillor hurley or councillor
hutchings
councillor hutchings sorry my mouse died
change battery
um four thank you cancel inch
four councillor james
or chancellor jones
four councillor langford
four councillor laws or
councillor leather four councillor lock
or councillor mcgoff four
councillor newton
councillor pennington councillor watson
thank you that's 34 and one against
chair
thank you very much that's clearly
carried thanks for that
so next week we got item 15 petition
right so uh let me move to 16 notice of
motion
uh a from cancer laws if you'd like to
explain the council why you want that
supported
council of laws and then i'll ask for a
second there
right um thank you very much uh chair
uh chair i better read it um because
there's been a lot of paper tonight and
there are
cancers who might not have got to it
recognizing the adverse effect on the
natural environment
of cheap discarded polystyrene
it is proposed that torres district
council fully support
a local campaign to request retailers
not to sell this type of bodyboard now
i appreciate chair it is not our place
to tell
traders what to sell and what not to
sell
but this campaign is just to make them
aware
of the situation and the fact that there
are alternatives
available this is a problem of our
generation
our making not us personally but
people like us they invented this
wonderful thing called polystyrene
now uh it's basically a little
tiny little tiny pellets of
polystyrene these are compressed
bonded and turned into bodyboards
and millions of these little beads right
so
the boards naturally just break there
they just break up and they're left on
beaches
and after a year or so what you have
is little pieces like that of
polystyrene
a year later they've reverted to their
nat their nature
little tiny pellets algae grows on these
in the sea
they sink fish eat them
there are billions of these they we
don't see them they're on the beaches
they're
everywhere we can avoid this happening
and i think we should because it's it
fits with our
own policy we're trying to we're trying
to make our way
forward they tell us if you go into the
sargasso sea in the middle of the
atlantic
there are literally hundreds of square
miles
of polystyrene plastic bottles and the
rest of it
now chair i'm going to ask because
the trade shows that these retailers buy
at
uh in january i'm actually going to
request that you may consider lifting
standing orders so we could just take a
simple vote as to whether
we support this campaign it's supported
by
our mp it's estimated in the west of
england that there are 16
000 of these boards left on beaches in a
broken
state and and we with a simple vote then
this is going to be a big campaign
they're going to go right throughout the
west of england
um that if we could make a vote tonight
we could publicize this
before those trade shows chair and we
could make a real difference i mean i
know we've had a night of total reports
but what i would say to you is we can
actually make a difference tonight
thank you chair thank you uh right do i
have a second there for a counsellor
councillor clark councillor clark would
like to second council of laws
thank you very much right i've got some
speakers here uh
first councillor haims thank you jer
well i think council laws has put a very
strong case to members
um these boards are pernicious they they
break into thousands millions of
fragments and they stay in the
environment for
i think centuries actually and they they
land up on beaches
they land up in the guts of sea birds
absolutely appalling um i think
you know this is a very worthwhile
campaign for us as a council
to support um i think the alternatives
being offered are a rental scheme
and also um that's um
suggesting retailers sell more durable
boards
and i fully support this resolution
good cancer christie
thank you yes i was gonna second it if
nobody else did but
um i wonder if we shouldn't actually add
an amendment to this because
it's already aware of council of law
saying you know you can't dictate to
retailers what they buy but the
government can surely outlaw these
things
um you know do we make them in britain
or do we import them probably from china
i don't see why we i was glad to hear
that our mp supports it i wonder if we
should approach them
in parliament and say cannot we just
outlaw these boards all together
it seems a bit odd to amount to campaign
just not to sell them
because people can buy them off the
internet you know there's all sorts of
ways of getting them
but we should outlaw them i think and i
wonder if council laws would accept an
amendment
to his motion that we actually do ask
our mps bring this up in parliament
to outlaw these boards all together
i don't know if there's a seconders of
that but well well why not have
otherwise you have to go yet another
vote two votes
had a addendum to the end of what
council laws said if he wishes to
to uh at the end of the sentence there
to uh
and to outlaw such products
what do you think council laws yes
request the government i think
all right that way we could still vote
on it and we could still
get the message to the retailers there's
been a lot of goodwill
and a lot of retailers are already
bagging yes
yeah thank you right so you're amending
your own notice of motion then to
not amending it you're adding an
addendum
yes to uh outlaw to request government
to outlaw
the production the uh sale of these um
boards
yes right okay uh no still got some
speakers uh councillor langford was next
i think
um i just want to say that um i'm pretty
sure this is going to town and parish
councils as well and it would be really
great if torridge led the way
um i'm all for it thank you very good
councillor bushby
thank you chair you know i'm quite happy
to personally support
um a request like this i think the point
has been very
well made um and i'm i'm also happy that
taurus district council
supports a local campaign but i don't
think it should be seen that tolerance
district council
are leading a local campaign i don't
want this to go out
on tourist district council headed new
paper for example
but i'm quite happy for you as chairman
or um steve hurst's chief executive
to add their name as in their positions
of torres strait council
but i don't think it's up to the council
to be actually
driving this we support it by all means
as long as we're not driving it because
there are an awful lot of
other polystyrene um
products just within the time whether
it's polystyrene
cups that you get in coffee shops
polystyrene packaging except you know
where do we stop with that
but i think the point that this is
something that is in the marine
environment and if we can
aim to you know reduce its impact it's
fine
but um it's in a supporting role only
right cancer hatchings um yeah i think
i'm just gonna
back up what counselor bushby just said
there um i know
our um town council we've discussed um
plastic free
towns and things like that and i i i
would hate to see us um
start where do we stop you know if we
start deciding on
banning certain things and certain
products um
there is no end to it you know pubs with
plastic bottles
water bottles you name it um see i think
it's a massive step to take if you start
banning one product
because the the end this will be endless
well
it's this is a specific marine product i
think which is uh
we're not we're not discussing plastic
cups this is just one
one particular item however uh and there
was some
tom i don't think there's any more
speakers are there i'm going to go to
the vote oh there's one more chair
councillor heppell
oh sorry councillor havel megapixel i
just wanted to point out that the motion
is to support
a local campaign it's not to drive it or
direct it to support it
thank you exchange that's what we're
voting on
that we're voting on the notice of
motion with the addendum at the end so
i'm going to go to the vote now okay
okay i think you just need to check that
counselor clark
still wishes to second the revised
promotion fine yes that's fine carry on
good
good thank you all right so um
let's say kirsty if you'd like to read
the names
thank you chair councillor belton uh
four
councillor brenton four councillor
bright
full chancellor brown or
councillor bushby or cancer christie
oh council clark
councillor cottle hunking boo that's the
darts
or councillor ford or
councillor club or councillor hackett
for councillor haynes or
councillor harding for councillor
hawkins
or councillor heppel or
councillor hicks or councillor hudson
or councillor hurley or
councillor hutchings
james for councillor langford
four councillor laws four
counselor leather or counselor lock
or counselor mcguff four
councillor newton paul councillor
pennington
councillor watson that's unanimous chair
thank you very much now we're going to
go back to
item six uh where i correspondence
brought by the chair and propose that we
go into part two
so that um steve hurst can update us on
the situation vp
1610. so i've got a second after that
second phil pennington thank you very
much so
kirsty to the vote again please
thank you chair councillor belton for
councillor brenton yeah councillor
bright
or councillor brown or
councillor bushby or councillor christie
oh councillor clark or
councillor cottle hunkin or
councillor dart oh counselor ford
or house look up for
council hacking for
haines or councillor harding
for councillor hawkins or
councillor heppell or councillor hicks
for councillor hudson or
councillor hurley or councillor
hutchings
councillor inch or
counselor james or casler jones
or thank you chancellor langford
or councillor leather or
councillor lock or counselor mcgough
or newton
pennington councillor watson
that's 34 and one against chair
thank you very much well um those
members of the public following us on
youtube thank you very much for your
attendance
uh we now have to uh um
hit you from the rest of the debate and
um
hope you have a very uh happy christmas
under the circumstances